one of the great things i think about 60
symbols brady is that
we've been doing them for a while now
and we've covered quite a new few topics
and of course it's not that you do a
video about a topic and then everyone
who's researching into that topic says
oh there's a 60 symbols video let's not
work on it anymore they carry on there
was an update by the ligo consortium
these are this this amazing group of
experiments which were the first direct
detection of gravitational waves
and the consequences of this has opened
up a new field of astronomy really which
we can call multi-messenger astronomy
which we can describe the first
observation was in 2015 and then by 2017
its significance was recognized enough
to get three of them nobel prizes so
we're heading on for six years on
they've released their third set of data
they've now got 90 events which might
not sound like a lot given that you've
been analyzing things for six years but
when you realize the majority of these
events are from colliding black holes so
black holes which have been orbiting
each other and then collided together
merged if you like coalesce is the
technical term produce gravitational
waves waves ripples in the space time
of our geometry which they've then
propagated out
and arrived at these detectors
if i tell you it's taken over a billion
years
basically for each of these events to
arrive at our detector it kind of gives
you a feel for okay these are very
sensitive detectors
[Music]
they're fairly rare events but the fact
that they've managed to go from one in
2015 up to actually they've reported on
35 in their last run which was from
november 2019 to march 2020. so it shows
you that they're ramping up that they're
they're getting their detectors sort of
they're homing in on how to get them as
precise as possible they're reducing all
the possible errors and their
sensitivities are increasing
and we're finding some really quite
beautiful results emerging and i thought
i'd just sort of try and give an update
on where i think
we are with it and uh maybe just a
little reminder of what ligo is so ligo
there's the ligo and virgo are the two
main detectors there's that ligo has got
two detectors themselves in america
one in louisiana and one in washington
state
each of the detectors are made up of two
arms which are about four kilometers
long they call they're called an
interferometer laser beams are shown up
and down each of these arms with
incredible accuracy so at the end of
each of the arms there's mirrors and
these mirrors are suspended in such a
way there they basically are in free
fall they don't feel the seismic
vibrations or the thermal fluctuations
or the experiments can handle all of
these potential
problems they have
but the laser beams bounce off the
mirrors
and the idea and then they they
recombine them so one set of laser beams
has gone down one arm and the other set
has gone down the other arm and then
they bring them back and recombine them
and they look for path differences
and they set it up initially so that
there's no path difference and then the
idea is if a gravitational wave a
distortion of the space time
comes by
it will distort one of these ever so
slightly
and then you'll see
these two beams will have passed a
different distance from one another and
they'll pick up an interference pattern
and just to give you an idea of the
sensitivity
these these lasers are traveling four
kilometers the distortion that we expect
to arrive from these gravitational waves
which just remind you of typically come
from a pair of black holes which have
been orbiting each other a billion years
ago coalesced together it's been
traveling for a billion years at the
speed of light passed through the
detector it distorts the detector by 10
to the minus 21 centimeters the size of
a proton
is 10 to the minus 18 centimeters this
is a thousand times less than the radius
of a proton
so the the sensitivity of this
experiment is quite staggering and so
there's one in louisiana there's one in
in washington state and there's one in
italy there's a new one that has just
come on board in japan as well making
four sets of detectors in the next
decade there's going to be one coming in
in india let's stick with the two in the
us what they look for is if this
gravitational wave has come in say and
hit the one in louisiana
then they don't interact with anything
they just carry on through distorting
the space time ever so small
and then it will eventually go through
the one in
washington state and so what the the
detectors look for is joint events they
look for the same signal
from that signal they have two ways then
of determining what they're finding they
have a bank of what you call templates
these are like
images that they have already calculated
that they know what certain objects
should do what the signal should look
like so two black holes merging they
know what they should look like
two neutron stars merging they think
they know what that should look like a
black hole and a neutron star merging
together they think that what that they
know what that should look like so they
then compare
these images to these templates
and by then tweaking the parameters of
the models for the templates they can
see which best fits the data
and that's how they've been able to
give so much information about the black
holes but they've got another way which
i had forgotten about and this other way
is imagine there's out there an object
which we haven't yet discovered and deep
down i know brady that the real reason
you've got into this is that you do have
your own star let's call it the bradeon
the bradeon star it's a compact object
we've yet to see it
and in particular we don't yet know what
happens when two radions collide
together
so they have this other way that so the
ligo people say don't worry brady we'll
find it
and what they look for is a second way
of analyzing the deities they just look
for the synchronicity of of the events
coming through
and if the events that go through
washington state and ligo and and
louisiana
look
very similar to one another then they
can take them out and begin to probe
look look at those events themselves
they don't need the templates
and from it
eventually they'll they'll probably have
to wait for a second brady on star
merger to occur they'll be able to sort
of infer we've got some new thing out
there and that's what one of the things
they're doing they look for
unexpected events that we don't yet know
what what are forming them aren't there
particles called radions have you got
your own particles as well there already
are bradeon's i've been wanting to ask
you about them for years okay we'll do
that another day we'd better look them
up so of course we had the first
detection of the of in 2015 which was
phenomenal in its own right in 2017 they
then discovered and we've we have
discussed this briefly but i think it's
worth mentioning
they discovered their first
case of neutron stars merging together
and what was so important about that is
when black holes merge together the only
thing that sort of produced as
gravitational waves that propagate out
but neutron stars are full of neutrons
and so when they merge together you not
only produce gravitational waves from
the from the
as you distort the space time with the
great masses of the of the neutron stars
but because they've got neutrons in
there you produce electromagnetic
radiation as well and so now what you
can look for is detecting both the
electromagnetic radiation the
gravitational waves and one of the key
results that came from this 2017
observation was that the the
gravitational waves and the
electromagnetic radiation the x-rays
arrived
sort of on
on earth in fact there was a satellite
just above earth detecting the elect the
x-rays within 1.7 seconds of each other
so they've been traveling for 300
million years to get to us
so to arrive within 1.7 seconds over
that distance means that these two waves
are traveling at the same speed or
extremely close to the same speed that
had the knock-on effect of ruling out a
whole load of cosmological models of
modified gravity which we're trying to
understand the acceleration of our
universe by modifying general relativity
and then there's one observation whoosh
so there were some theories that were
saying that the gravitational waves and
the electromagnetic waves should have
been traveling at different speeds
exactly and
one of them was ours
the fab four was one of them oh you lost
it
yeah we made a video about that one we
did you'll have to just bend that one
now it's a nice idea i think i really
think it's quite a nice idea it may all
collapse
that's the nature of research so they've
carried on of course making more
observations and the most recent set uh
they announced 35 new
candidates there's a beautiful picture
you can see that you you of the black
holes and
of
that it's not it's a diagrammatic
representation of what's happening of
these 35 candidates 32 are black hole
black holes
orbiting each other and coalescing
within that there's some really
interesting features one of them that's
that's got people quite excited is that
they're beginning to see black holes of
large black holes
masses of order 60 70 solar masses
coalescing together and they're
beginning to see these what are known as
intermediate scale mass black holes and
no one really understands how they form
and so and but they're beginning to see
them in more abundance
even though
they're looking at you know they've got
90 events or so the rate at which
they're beginning to see them is already
pushing some of the
recognized models of intermediate black
hole formation to to their limits
they're also seeing some very light
black holes merging together and there's
a really interesting property of black
holes which i hadn't really thought
about
black holes of course are regarded as
being a so mass is not much above a
solar mass a few six five six solar mass
black holes merging together
it turns out the black holes ex change
the curvature of the space ties that's
why we talk about black holes as being a
great laboratory to test general
relativity because we can test the
strong curvature regime and you might
think to yourself oh that means you must
look at the really biggest black holes
they're going to have their biggest
impact
but actually they don't the black the
curvature of a compact object is
inversely proportional to the mass of
the object so the smaller the mass the
bigger the curvature so if you really
want to test strong gravity you want
light black holes actually merging
together the really big black holes the
really massive black holes by the time
you're out at the event horizon of the
black hole
the curvature is actually quite
quite low and so you're not really
testing the very strong regime so
they're seeing evidence of that and then
the other thing that they're seeing
evidence of which i think is really neat
now is that for the first time they're
seeing evidence of neutron stars and
black holes merging together
and the whole is that a merger that
seems really not a very equitable merger
is it more of a yeah
it's a snack
you see yes i think it's a snack i think
you're seeing the black hole snacking on
the neutron star so they've got one in
particular which they they think is
really fascinating it's a 30 solar mass
black hole and there's a 1.2 solar mass
neutron star that's just sort of being
merged into it eaten by it
and and that's at the very border of
when a neutron star can form but the
hope there is that that also because
it's a neutron star will be able to give
out electromagnetic radiation so you'll
be able to test you know the merger
properly you know how what happens as
the object goes across the event horizon
and
what can you tell from the form of the
of the waves that have been produced
another thing that they're finding which
i think is really interesting
is that black holes have associated with
them certain characteristics the mass is
one of them the spin is another one and
it's charged does it have any charges
another what they've now
finding sort of pretty concrete evidence
for in a number of the mergers is that
the the black holes that are emerging
have spin associated with them and
that's particularly interesting those
are called curve black holes
and what's particularly interesting
about that is that because you've got a
bit more information now about the spin
of the black hole whether it's spinning
quickly or spinning slowly then you've
got some information that you can
compare with your theories because
different theories
will predict different spins of black
holes depending on whether black holes
formed by objects passing by each other
really rapidly then you can imagine
they'll
have a lot of spin associated with them
or angular momentum or whether they just
simply objects merging together when you
you won't expect much and so by looking
at the distribution of the spins we're
once again going to be able to test
theories of black hole formation another
element which they've got very good data
on is first of all the distance scale
out to these objects and as i said black
holes are typically finding black holes
at orders of giga parsecs remember what
i say the parsec's three light years
this is of order three billion years the
light's been traveling
the earth was forming around the time
when some of these coalescent objects
were were
meeting one another it's just so
remarkable that we can get death
like this another thing that is of
interest to people who are trying to
understand the nature of black holes and
their merging is
if two black holes come together what's
the likelihood that they're near equal
masses as opposed to one being
completely dominant over the other and
they're able to get that kind of
information out of this as well
so you know i hope you get the
impression there's a lot going on there
and the there's a lot for the theorists
to sort of mull over and get into to try
and understand
this amazing area and
the future is just mind-blowing as to
what we'll be able to do as they upgrade
the detectors we'll be able to see d
print of the universe if you see deeper
into the universe just imagine a cone
coming out from you and going deeper and
deeper and deeper you see more and more
of the sky so you can see more and more
events
and then you'll eventually begin to be
able to probe early universe phenomena
that's that's the hope that we might be
able to see evidence of phase
transitions in the early universe or
something that i would love is if we saw
any evidence of cosmic strings emitting
their gravitational waves so that's one
of the things advanced ligo is still
looks for that's called the stochastic
background of radiation and now with the
the japanese gravitational wave detector
coming on board and the indian one in in
the next decade having more and more
detectors just means that you've got
better resolution as to where the
gravitational waves are formed from and
this is going to have an absolutely
amazing impact eventually because
there's a thing out there called the
hubble tension we've spoken about the
hubble tension that's this idea the
universe is expanding and if you measure
the expansion rate using distant
measurements like the cosmic microwave
background you get one value if you
measure the expansion rate using
supernovae which are closer you get
another value and these two values are
not overlapping
both of those processes
rely on you understanding the cosmology
of the system
some to estimate the luminosity distance
to these objects this method with
gravitational waves doesn't do that all
the information is wrapped up in the
signal that we get
and so as long as you can pinpoint how
far away the object is
and actually the polarization of the
light then actually
the expansion rate of the universe will
pop out it will come out it'll be a
direct measurement it'll probably the if
they can get enough data enough objects
to test it'll be within a few years a
one percent few percent measurement of
the hubble expansion rate which will be
a massive feature and there's so many
other things that are out there waiting
to be detected it's a this whole period
of gravitational wave and
multi-messenger
exploration is fantastic why is it
called multi-messenger because it so it
will this is multi-messenger means when
there's two sets of waves at least two
sets different sorts gravitational waves
and electromagnetic waves those are the
two usual multi messenger but it could
also be neutrinos for example being
emitted which get will get emitted when
neutron stars collide together you told
me before about how
subtle and small the signal received is
just this tiny tiny
uh deviation in this laser caused by the
gravitational waves
and presumably also sometimes a little
bit of light or x-rays sometimes as well
on the other hand you tell me about the
incredible detail that this is shedding
on intricate events that are happening
at the edge of a black hole as a neutron
star is swallowed and things like that
can you really glean that much
information about
subtle things happening
at that kind of scale just from
such small data from such a trivial
little blip here on earth
okay i've not heard the ligo data being
described in trivial little blip
but it is like like all it is is like a
flicker it's a flicker a tiny flicker
and i realize the repercussions of it
but it doesn't seem like a lot of
information to reconstruct the collision
of two black holes absolutely crucial
question it's the question right and um
the the point is remember i mentioned
the templates
so the templates what they're really
telling you is
you're solving general relativity
equations
for two black holes of some mass maybe
some spin
and you you believe in general
relativity you have to believe for this
to to work or you could modify it and do
the same thing and that's also done
and you
you solve the equation so the black
holes are
merging they're merging they're merging
and what you're predicting out of your
temple your solutions are the solutions
for the gravitational waves the
distortion of the space time and what
you you actually predict over what time
scale the amplitude and frequency of
that wave should change you have a very
precise prediction for a given set of
masses
you preser and and there's a little
chirp at the end usually that happens
just as they merge together so that's
your template that's your theory right
you've done it on some big super
computer
what the data is doing what the ligo
observatories are doing is they're
measured they're detecting that
and they actually detect over you're
quite right it's over a relatively short
period of time but they detect the final
in-falls of the of the black hole
and so there's a precise they detect a
precise thing and actually a blip at the
end
and then what they can do so that's the
data it's got some amplitude and some
frequency over a very short time scale
the the significance of the precision of
the experiment is really in that
it's just staggering that they can
measure this and have it having
subtracted out all the other noise
the the the trend that goes by the
you know the the detector
the crocodile that walks along the
ground that must be producing a
vibration bigger than the the radius of
a proton atom right
proton nucleus and
the fact that they feel they can do that
is the stunning thing the observation is
of
some wave
and then what they do is they have a
whole bank of templates of different
masses of black holes and they basically
compare you told me about how some of
these findings had actually shot down
a theory that you had hoped may have
some value
to what extent has looking through all
this data got you working on new
theories like how much is it
how much is it affecting your work yeah
i mean i've it i have started thinking
now about
i've worked on objects
which can be compact they're called
ocelons which can can collapse and and
and then form live for a long time
and oscillate
it has made me decide i think we really
need to understand the template of these
objects because they're they're believed
to have been relevant in the early
universe
in fact as the period of inflation ends
they could go through a period of
forming these ocelons
and we've did some initial calculations
of our salons orbiting one another but
i've never
been been involved in a project where
we've taken it really seriously and
tried to understand the template and and
reading about this learning about this
has made me think yeah actually i would
really like to do that and the other
objects i've always been interested in
and in fact
my wonderful phd student despina just
finished her phd last year on its cosmic
strings and looking at the emission from
cusps of strings and so that's a we've
also been working on that to see whether
or not we can
find the template that that they can use
for liger but liga already have a very
good bank of people working on the
cosmic strings
so that's kind of already sorted but the
ocelons and those objects not so and i
think i'd love to know about them
worry about you know what this means but
as you can see we've named them john
paul
george and ringo okay so so yeah so we
sent it off to the uh to the journal and
it immediately came back without having
been
assessed by by any any experts just
saying um
there's no way we're gonna publish uh a
paper with all these references to the
beatles in it uh in view of the beatles
limited contribution to cosmology